- [Voiceover] Find the
eighth term of the sequence
1440, 1716, 1848,
and so on and so forth,
whose terms are formed by multiplying
the corresponding terms of
two arithmetic sequences.
Arithmetic sequences,
always having trouble
saying that properly.
So, let's think about the two sequences
and then we'll take the
products of corresponding terms
to get the terms of this sequence.
So maybe one of the arithmetic
sequences starts with A,
starts with A, and then the next one,
the next term in that sequence
is going to be some constant plus A,
that's what an arithmetic sequence is.
It's just a constant added
to each successive term.
So, it's going to be A, A plus M,
and then the next term
would be M plus A plus M,
or it'd be A plus two M.
And if we just kept going, what we care
is all the way to the eighth term
because we're gonna take the eight term
of this sequence, multiply
it by the eighth term
of the other sequence
to get the eighth term
of this sequence over here.
So, the second term, we only added one M,
the third term, we added two M's,
so the eighth term, we're
gonna add seven M's,
one less than the term.
The first term, we added zero M's.
So, the eighth term here is going to be,
is going to be A plus, A plus 7m.
That's the eighth term of
this arithmetic sequence.
Now, let's do another one for
another arithmetic sequence,
maybe that starts at the number B.
Now, the next term is going
to be some constant plus B,
so let's just call that B plus N.
Then the third term
will be N plus B plus N.
So, it'll be B plus 2n.
And then we go all the
way to the eighth term
by the same logic, it's going
to be B plus, B plus 7n.
The difference between
each of these terms is N.
Now, they tell us that the product
of the corresponding terms
of these two sequences
are the terms of this sequence.
so, A times B, so when
you take the product
of A and B, we get A times B,
A times, I'll color code it for here,
A times B is going to be equal to 1440.
1400, 1440.
We also know that A plus
M, we also know that
A plus M times B plus N,
times B plus N is going to be equal to,
is going to be equal to 1716.
1716.
We also know, we also know that A plus 2m,
A plus 2m times B plus 2n,
times B plus 2n is going to be
equal to 1848.
Is going to be equal to 1848.
And if we want the eighth
term of this sequence,
we just have to take this
product right over here.
So, the eighth term is going to be,
is going to be A plus 7m, A plus 7m
times B plus 7n.
Times B plus, B plus 7n.
Now, before I even do this, it seems like
we have some good information to at least
put some constraints around
our A's, B's, M's, and N's.
Let's just think about the form
that this is going to take, and then maybe
we can kind of build up the numbers
as we solve for this stuff over here.
So, the eighth term in our
sequence is going to be,
I'll do this in a new
color, it's going to be,
let's just multiply
these two binomials out,
A times B, it's going to be AB,
that's A times B, plus A times 7n,
so that's plus 7an, plus 7m times B,
so plus 7bm, plus 7m times 7n.
7m times 7n, so that's plus 49,
plus 49mn, 49, 49mn.
So, this is what we need
to figure out the value of.
We need to figure out the
value of this right here.
Well, we already know
one of the terms here.
We already know that A
times b is equal to 1440.
So, we're already making some head way.
This right here is going
to be equal to 1440.
Now, let's see if we can figure
out anything for these terms
over here using the other
information over here.
So, let's multiply these out.
So, let me do this once
again in a new color.
So, if I multiply this
out, I got A times B,
which is AB plus A times N, which is AN,
plus M times B, or B times M, which is BM,
plus M times N, plus M times N.
Which is going to be equal to 1716.
Now, we know that AB is 1440.
We know that this is 1440.
So let's see, let's subtract
1440 from both sides
of this equation, I'll
switch colors again.
So, let's subtract 1440.
Well, I guess I didn't switch colors.
>From both sides of this equation,
these guys obviously cancel out,
the left hand side becomes AN plus BM
plus MN is equal to, let's see,
the thousands cancel out,
we have a 671 minus 40,
let's see, we have a
six minus zero is six.
Then we can borrow, this is a six,
this is 11, 11 minus four is seven,
six minus four is two,
one minus one is zero.
So, AN plus BM plus MN is equal to 276.
So, we got that information using this
and that, that, essentially, equation.
Now let's use this equation over here.
Do this in a new color,
I'm running out of colors.
I'll do it in green.
So, we have A times B, which is AB
plus A times 2n.
So, it's 2an.
Plus 2mb times, 2m times B,
so it's plus 2bm.
Plus 2m times 2n, so plus four,
plus 4mn is equal
to 1848.
Well, same idea, this AB, this is 1440.
We can subtract 1440 from
both sides of this equation.
I'm running out of space
here so I'm just gonna
subtract 1440 from the
left and the right side.
Now this equation becomes,
on the left hand side,
we're just left with this stuff over here.
So, we have 2an.
I'm gonna write it over here
so it doesn't look confusing.
We have 2an plus 2bm
plus 4mn is equal to, these
obviously cancelled out.
848 minus 440 is 408.
Is equal to 408, did I do that right?
848, yeah, 408, right.
And now both sides of this equation
are divisible by two, so let's
divide both sides by two.
So, we have, if we
divide everything by two,
you get AN pus BM
plus 2mn is equal to,
is equal to 204.
Now, these look pretty close.
It's actually, if we view, if we view this
as kind of one variable,
and this as another,
seems like we can solve for MN,
and then we can solve for AN BM.
And the reason why that looks useful,
the reason why that would be useful
is our final answer, we
have some multiple times MN.
So, if we know what MN is, we
could put that number here,
and if we know what AN plus BM is,
we just multiply that
seven, and we're gonna get
this term right over
here, so let's do that.
Let's do that, let's solve for MN.
And to solve for MN, let's
subtract this equation
from this equation.
So, let me do it in that same color.
So, I'm gonna subtract
this from this equation.
So, multiply it by negative one.
We have negative AN minus BM
minus MN is equal to
negative 276, is equal to negative 276.
And then when we subtract, we get,
these cancel out, these cancel
out, and then 2mn minus MN
is just gonna be MN.
And then 204 minus 276, that's negative,
negative 72.
So, we're able to solve for MN.
And that's useful for us because
this expression here is 49mn.
So, this number right here,
this number right here
is negative, that number
right there is negative 72.
Now, what's AN plus BM?
Well, we know that this
right here is negative 72.
This right here is negative 72.
So, let's add 72 to both
sides of this equation.
So, plus 72.
We get on the left hand side, AN plus BM,
these cancel out, is equal to,
so six plus two is eight,
seven plus seven is 14,
you have a one up there,
one plus two is three.
So, it's 348.
So, the eighth term in our sequence,
which we figured out, which we figured out
was this business over
here, it is equal to AB.
Which is the same thing as 1440.
Plus, plus this thing over here.
Plus this thing, which
is just the same thing
as seven times, let me write it up here.
This thing over here in
blue is the same thing
as seven times AN plus BM.
Now, we know that AN plus BM is 348,
so it's seven times 348.
And then finally, finally, plus, plus
this thing over here, plus 49 times MN.
49, or we could say minus 49 times 72.
So, let me just, so what this is,
you could say 49 times negative 72.
This is going to be the
eighth term in our sequence,
so let's figure out, let's
figure out what this thing,
what this thing even is.
So, let's see how we can,
let's see how we can do it.
Well, we could just multiply it out.
So, seven times 348.
I have no calculator at my disposal,
seven times 348.
Eight times seven is 56.
Four times seven is 28 plus three is,
or, plus five is 33.
Three times seven is 21 plus three is 24.
So this is 2436.
If we add that to 1440,
so, if you add it to,
did I do that right?
Seven times eight is 56,
seven times four is 28,
plus five is 33.
Yup, that's right.
So then we add the 1440 over here.
We get six seven eight three, 3876.
So, that's this whole part over here.
That's all of this business.
And then we have to take 49 times 72
and then subtract it from this.
So, let's take 49 times 72.
Two times nine is 18,
two times four is eight,
plus one is nine, stick a zero here.
Nine times seven is 63.
Seven times four is 28 plus six is 34.
34, so this is eight, 12,
carry the one, five, and three.
So, we're gonna subtract 3528.
So, we get, what do we get here?
So, this becomes a 16, this becomes a six,
16 minus eight is eight.
Six minus two is four.
Eight minus five is three and then
three minus three is zero.
So, the eighth term in this sequence,
the eighth term in this sequence
is going to be, I just
wrote it down, it is 348.
348.
And we're done.